[Music]
let's go to
nova we'll go to supernova in austin
texas what's up nova
hey how's it going partying what are you
up to
uh just working it's a monday i know i'm
at work too i'm not partying at all i
just lie to myself it feels
it's raining outside it's just one of
those days so we're having a party so
what's up nova
um so
i am
in um
i'm a bit of a unicorn or so i've been
told
um
um i'm in kind of a situation where i
don't really know how to navigate the um
the relationships going forward in my
life
so i am 39
i
have been married a few times
um the first time i got married i
it was
volatile and
you know not a good situation and so
that marriage was short-lived i you know
divorced at about
i think i was like 25 by the time i
divorced
um remarried and and it was my happily
ever after
um or so i thought um we were married
about nine years and he passed away
um drunk driving oh man
he was drunk driving or somebody hit him
he was oh man i'm so sorry
and
um
together we were raising my son from my
previous marriage and so you know
um i was
after i lost him you know
single mom in it through grief and
um
you know that was a struggle
um for a couple of years and i
s at about the one one and a half year
mark i started feeling like my normal
self again
changed but you know the new normal
um
and i opened myself back up to love and
went out there and you know
i i felt good again um and so i started
dating
um reunited with
an old friend from high school we hit it
off
um
things were going great we got married
um
and
we were married a little over a year
and
covert happened
and
he died
come coming out the front door are you
serious
um we're going on a year now god
almighty i'm so sorry
yeah just got sick and passed away how
how long was it between when he got sick
till when he passed away
three weeks
he was
you know 40 no pre-existing conditions
no nothing that was alarming and
he got coveted and
we thought he was just sleeping it off
you know like the first couple of days
he was just very tired and
and on day three when i went in to
check on him i noticed his lips were
turning blue and i was like oh my
goodness we're going to the hospital and
we live
you know three miles from the hospital
so i rushed in there and and
within a day he was intubated never came
home huh yeah
do you have it so across these three
marriages do you have kids involved in
this too
right so that's where that's where it
gets tricky so
um
you know his his he has two daughters
i have my son
um and
his daughters came to live with us
the january
so they've been with us a little over a
year now year and a half okay
how old are they um
20 and almost 16. okay
so one's still a minor one's one's an
adult right okay
and they came a little bit
how old your son
he's 18. okay
and who's his
dad his dad is jesse he was my first
husband okay all right cool yeah so he
still gets visitation with his dad and
um he's 18 now so he's kind of free to
the world now right yeah okay yeah yeah
so all right so hot now thank you for
playing that i'm you've been through a
lot and i'm so sorry that is a lot of
trauma good grief
yeah yeah in a short amount of time yes
yes yes
okay so years past so are you are you
back out
so i'm back out okay um you know i'm i'm
doing well considering everything like
the thing is it's
you know kind of the way that i explain
it to people unfortunately it's almost
like muscle memory like i've already i
know how to walk the walk yeah
and so
i'm good i'm working full-time i'm
holding down the fort at home i still
have my
social life and you know i'm
i'm good um you've grieved this
i have okay yeah okay yeah
i'm not in mourning yep i i do still
grieve sometimes of course absolutely
but it's not that deep deep yeah that
black hole that's right that's right
okay
so you're back out there
so i'm dating what's his name
don't tell me his name
okay david okay yeah
um he's great um
he's very understanding of the situation
he knows you know yeah he knows what
he's getting into
hey listen he has no idea what he's
getting into not even close
but i like that he believes that he does
that's cool good for him yeah
yeah
the the hard part for me is you know
first and foremost i'm thinking about
the kids you know and
and they
we talk a lot and you know i
i don't put them in situations where i
feel like they're not ready you know we
are all kind of walking through this and
sometimes it feels like we're walking
through mud but we're you know we make
it through and and we're doing okay
and they you know they've met him they
like him
we're all adjusting well okay where it
gets tricky is
um
because they are my late husband's kids
and they live with me i'm getting
custody
okay
um
they you know still have a relationship
with his family and they still want a
relationship with his family and
and i do too to some extent but things
are a little bit different now right
and
you know take for example this past
easter there was a big family
easter barbecue
and
they were like oh we're going right like
the whole family they want to go
and
you know
i i feel
like i want to be there i want to be
part of
the family that they so desperately want
because their family has slowly started
you know with their dad passing and then
grandpa passed you know a couple months
later like
they want that family
um so let me just different so
distill this down into a question for me
how do i
blend
my
new
relationship going forward because we're
we're at the point where
we don't we're at the point where we're
blending lives we want we're wanting to
do things together as a family okay
so um here's my here's like let me just
i'll hop in let me here's my thoughts on
it
if you're adopting
these two
if you are taking guardianship of them
especially the minor
you are taking guardianship you are you
are opting into their entire family
the same as you did when you married him
okay
i think they're right
especially when they're a minor i think
you go to the family events
and if you're um
they need that level
of security you've been through this
before they have not
you're an adult and it's brutal and you
you know the black hole
they are kids and that black hole will
be in they will be in that black hole
for years
and so having strings and connections to
let me say it this way you can't adopt
these two kids and then just have them
cut off their families and say we're
starting something new that can't right
that can't work yeah so i think i think
it's right and fair to
let your new
boyfriend who might become your fiance
who might become your new husband
someday
say this is part of what we do is we go
visit
and i've got people in my life that are
friends who married somebody whose
spouse passed away and they go visit and
it's kind of weird
and that's just part of what happens
when you sign up for a blended family
it's just different it's a challenge
every blended family situation is
different
the cornerstone is a we got to take care
of these kids first they got to feel
safe and connected both to their lineage
and their legacy and to what we're doing
that's new
right that's number one and number two
is we're kind of all making this up as
we go so we have to over over over
communicate
when your new boyfriend says hey i feel
weird there he needs to have permission
and space to say it and you don't fly
off the handle at him and when you say i
don't really feel like going you get to
be able to say that to him and him be
able to say yeah but it's probably the
right thing
and it's that weird balance of that 16
year old in that especially the 20 year
old that 16 year old doesn't get to hurt
your feelings and at the same time she's
hurting so bad god almighty so bad so
bad right and so let's go see
grandmother and granddad let's just make
that a part of what we're going to do
every year
that make sense
yeah
i think
the tendency to want to clear the deck
and move on from this hurt is going to
be there's going to be a really
attractive pull to that for you
is that fair
from for me not the kids like i i never
want them just like i
i'm completely
great with them going in to see their
family like i don't want to pull them
from that but i do find myself
you know kind of
stepping back because they his family
knows i'm dating and i don't want
anybody to feel disrespected i don't
want them to feel like oh i don't think
yeah
and if they do call them
say hey i'm dating somebody new and
we're all coming would it be okay if i
brought him
i think you for the next four years next
two or three years i think you i think
you go
to these type of family events or
whatever
at graduation i think you invite her
grandparents and her aunts and uncles
and cousins and you have them over to
your house even if you're married by
then
right everybody nobody is under the
illusion that you know what i mean like
it's it's the secrets that are gonna
start to cause fissures and cracks in
the family
and so we're just gonna keep secrets and
if somebody says hey we really would
prefer you not to bring your new
boyfriend over to the house it's just
it's just too soon for us say great cool
i'm just gonna be respectful because
this isn't about them it's not about
getting in a fight nick well this is me
no it's about those kids
right and then when they turn 18 and the
other one's 22 now we're having a whole
different conversation you don't have to
go to all those things anymore because
they're adults and they can go to where
they want to right
i think it's not overthinking it and
also not
i mean you're doing a noble thing by
taking these kids
a truly noble thing
but by doing that
you're you're entrenching yourself in
this family for a season or really
forever but especially for us
right right right um
and i think that's good and i think it's
really hard
i think both of those can be the true at
the same time
does that does that make your heart hurt
to think about that
it
it makes me nervous
why
i
i just
um
i don't know like death brings out the
ugly in people and i'm i'm nervous that
because
i'm i would be with somebody new like if
you know he came with us to the
functions
that they would be
not
receptive to that and so what you're
doing right now is you're projecting
into the future something that hasn't
happened yet
and you are choosing to be anxious and
possibly make life altering family
decisions and choices over something
that hasn't happened yet and yet you
don't really have a clear answer on
and the only way you can get clear
answers in this there's two ways one you
can just show up and spring on them and
see what happens which is a terrible
idea or you can call ahead
you can send an email out to the family
you can let everybody know hey i'm
adopting these kids i'm gonna be all in
on this family and i am dating again and
if i bring somebody know that it's not
disrespect it's it's me wanting y'all to
know what's going on in my life and
y'all and me to know what's going on
y'all's life if anyone has any concerns
please reach out and let me know
and what we're doing here is we're not
trying to win this is about hospitality
this is about kindness and it's about
those kids
but i'm not gonna give any real estate
in my heart and mind for imagining
things that might or might go sideways
or someone might get mad or they may
think i'm moving on too quick that
sounds like you might be wondering if
you're moving on too quick not them but
they might be and they may say you he's
not welcome here you're not welcome here
okay
they're hurting
and if it brings out the ugly in them
that's fine i'm not gonna let them bring
out the ugly in me
i'm just not i'm not gonna give them
that power over my life
it's not
and you've been through a lot and so as
you walk through this nova give yourself
some grace okay give yourself some grace
be open with those kids be open with
your new boyfriend
make sure he's nice
make sure he's nice
and
man
communicate communicate communicate